[Music]
on this Wednesday night horror in Laval
Quebec a city bus crashes into a daycare
in what appears to be a deliberate act I
still can see his eyes you know how
Easter Ricky was the driver facing
charges including first degree murder
deepening desperation and diplomatic
difficulties in Syria you need to deal
with the government of Bashar Assad and
in Turkey earthquake survivors hope for
miracles in the rubble our Jackson
prosco is in the city of Adana
plus the claims Beijing tried to
interfere in Canadian democracy the
evidence suggesting the prime minister's
office knew about the threat years ago
National with Donna Friesen this is the
scene at a daycare in Laval Quebec after
a city bus crashed into the building in
what appears to have been a deliberate
act it happened at 8 30 this morning as
parents were dropping off their children
two of those children were killed six
other children are in hospital
good evening and thanks for joining us
police say the driver of that bus a 51
year old man who is a Transit employee
is facing two counts of first-degree
murder along with attempted murder and
assault that suggests this was not an
accident police are not disclosing more
information about a possible motive the
daycare though is not along a usual bus
route Mike Armstrong is in Lavelle for
us tonight Mike well Donna the biggest
question about what happened here behind
me really is motivation why did it
happen well the location clearly makes
it look intentional
this isn't a bus making a wrong move on
a busy Boulevard the driver had to go
out of his way to reach the daycare it's
located at the end of a dead end Road
and then the driver would have had to
make a right turn into a long driveway
streaming and the you know crying and
this woman was one of the first people
into the daycare after the crash she
lives nearby and says it was chaos she
also witnessed the takedown of the bus
driver according to Witnesses he exited
the bus naked and hysterical four men
jumped him and held him down until
police arrived I saw him when the police
dragged him in the vehicle his eye was
like popping out you know and he was new
he didn't have any pants
I I still can see his eyes you know how
history Ricky was that man according to
the city of Laval the driver had been
with the local bus service for a decade
he's 51 years old police won't say if he
had any known links to the daycare
possibly a child who went there or a
relationship with an educator will only
say the man faces serious charges has
been arrested
for careless driving and homicide now
according to some of the people who got
inside the daycare to help some of the
children were trapped in debris they
pulled one out but couldn't get to
another firefighters took over from
there
parts of the roof were falling on us
this man says they made us leave this
was a very traumatic morning for parents
the incident was just before 8 30 a.m
there would have been children still
being dropped off the children who were
okay after the crash were taken to a
safe place to wait they were then picked
up by panicked parents who then held
them understandably very tightly
I've seen my two little ones this
grandmother says they're good and not
traumatized
now services are being put in place for
the children and the parents counseling
to help them deal with what they went
through but this was a very difficult
crime scene with multiple very young
children as victims often cases like
this they'll be counseling for staff and
police things like that here within
hours they were even putting in a crisis
team to have counselors ready for the
paramedics to have them to help them
deal with what they went through Donna
Michael Armstrong and Laval Quebec that
anyone would intentionally drive a bus
into a daycare is impossible to
comprehend the driver faces two charges
of first degree murder plus charges of
attempted murder and aggravated assault
turia Israeli has more on what we know
about him
not far from the crash site police are
posted outside a home believed to be
where the alleged killer lived
51-year-old piagni saint-amo a longtime
employee of Laval transport
it's shocking says a co-worker it's
inexplicable
he was always smiling I have no idea
what happened
hours after the crash Saint Emma was
charged with two counts of first-degree
murder
Saint Thomas is being interrogated by
police photos from inside the daycare
show the destruction
the realization that the children may
have been targeted has sent a chill
across the country to rise
MPS stood for a moment of silence there
are no words
parents who've lost their children this
way Quebec Premier Francois logo is also
shaken all my thoughts are with the
children with the parents and with the
employees growing grief and so many
unanswered questions about the man
behind the wheel now charged with murder
tariya isri Global News Ottawa
now to Turkey and Syria where
desperation is building and the death
toll keeps Rising the number is
staggering more than 12 000 people are
known to have died even many of those
fortunate enough to have survived have
nothing left Rescuers face shortages of
trucks fuel equipment and time even as
they hear cries for help from those
still trapped
in some cases the cries are answered
this newborn was rescued from the rubble
in Southeastern turkey wrapped in a
blanket and carried away one life saved
but there's no word on his family the
future of so many young lives is
uncertain 16 rescued babies were
transferred to Turkey's capital on the
presidential plane the little
information that's known about them
is written on their foreheads Jackson
Prasco was in the earthquake zone
tonight Jackson Donna the Frantic search
and Recovery efforts continue around the
clock but in the bitter winter cold it's
an increasingly desperate Race Against
Time
there are holes in the skyline of Adana
places where buildings crumbled in the
middle of the night
all that's left is Rubble mixed with the
ghostly belongings of the missing and
the dead it's like a war you know what I
mean
we didn't know what was going on it's
really emotional to see but you cannot
do anything you know what I mean you
know both of iren's parents died when
their 14-story apartment building
collapsed as they slept she watched over
the Grimm's search waiting for Rescuers
to find her mother's body
I just want to be able to see my mother
she says I want to be able to pray for
her
the air is thick with dust and the smell
of death still Rescuers hope there might
be at least one Survivor in a place
where at least 60 people died
one block away there's another missing
Tower and more haunting signs of lives
cut short Adana is a city of high-rises
many of them are now structurally
compromised unsafe to occupy
and so the city's Parks have become
makeshift encampments hundreds more
tents are crammed into an outdoor Market
where people burn whatever they can find
to stay warm as volunteers deliver food
I just couldn't sit at home and do
nothing says this organizer I'm here to
share their pain
as night falls a fresh search begins at
yet another collapsed site with hand
tools and buckets they dig deep into the
ruins hoping to find a miracle in the
coming days are expected to bring a huge
increase in the amount of foreign aid
and the number of foreign search and
rescue workers on the ground but each
passing minute in these conditions only
increases the odds that their mission
will be focused more on recovery
Donna right Jackson prosco inadonna
turkey tonight thanks Canada's
International Development Minister says
an assessment team is on its way to
Turkey it's a handful of military and
Global Affairs officials not an actual
disaster relief team they will assess
what tools Canada can best use to
respond turkey's president visited the
earthquake zone today and he rejected
growing criticism of his government's
response to the earthquakes recipe
erdogan who faces re-election in May
that it's not possible to prepare for a
disaster of this scale erdogan was in
karaman Mirage today he met survivors
Sheltering intense he's facing a lot of
criticism for not deploying rescue crews
fast enough to all the affected cities
he acknowledged early problems in
turkey's response but says operations
are running smoothly now many Turks have
complained a lack of equipment and
support support prevented them from
reaching the buried there are reports
access to social media has been
restricted though it's not relief
efforts in Syria are an even bigger
challenge State media there is reporting
nearly three hundred thousand people
have been displaced that does not
include regions held by Rebel factions
in a country that's endured more than a
decade of War eight agencies are trying
to find a way in but the main land
routes such as this road connecting
turkey and Syria you can see are
severely damaged Ross Lord reports on
how the world including Canada is trying
to help
these are the images the world wants to
see a little girl stuck for more than a
day now freed and carried through crowds
of joyous onlookers
sadly more common are images like these
an earthquake Survivor explaining how he
lost 20 family members leaving him at
his two-year-old daughter to sort out
the future
my other young daughter died in my arms
he says and my wife died next to me
as other Assyrians donate blood and
personal possessions the outside world
is also looking for ways to help
including Canada as Canadian Red Cross
we are on the ground we we have some of
our delegates in Syria and in the region
and we're scaling up with additional
delegates people to support the Syrian
area red crescent the federal government
is matching contributions to the Red
Cross and Syrian Canadians hope their
Homeland isn't overlooked I was just
looking at the map of Syrian it was just
left alone
and no one really was was directing
their efforts to help those people
thousands of people that they're in
immediate need of help security analysts
say launching an effective relief effort
might be impossible with Road networks
and hospitals barely functioning in
Syria after 11 years of Civil War an
estimated 15 million syrians were in
need of humanitarian assistance before
the earthquake Canada and other Western
countries who've been punishing the
Syrian government with sanctions face
another predicament in providing help in
the case of Syria in particular
it is highly problematic because uh you
need to deal at some point or another
with the government of Bashar Assad they
have the grant permission there are some
promising news the United Nations
indicating deliveries of cross-border
aid from Turkey to Northwest Syria could
resume this week after being suspended
by the earthquakes as the Race Against
Time continues
lost Lord Global News
Ukraine's president made a surprise
visit to the UK today and received a
hero's welcome
but we've all been worried about you
thinking about your country
thanks so much Vladimir zielinski met
King Charles at Buckingham Palace and he
went to 10 Downing Street with the
British prime minister he got a standing
ovation as he addressed a joint session
of parliament at Westminster Hall
enski thanked Britain for being a loyal
Ally and he made an impassioned plea for
fighter jets offering the helmet of a
Ukrainian fighter pilot as a gift
he is one of our most successful
Aces and he's one of our Kings
and the writing on the helmet reads
we have freedom give us Wings to protect
it
Britain's prime minister says nothing is
off the table that fighter jets are part
of the conversation but nothing has been
promised zielinski then traveled to
France for a meeting with the French
president
accusations China tried to meddle in
Canadian elections coming up the
evidence suggesting the prime minister's
office knew about the threat years ago
we have an update to a story we first
brought you back in November about
China's alleged attempts to interfere in
Canada's Democratic process Global News
has seen evidence suggesting the prime
minister's office was looking into that
threat as early as 2017. well before the
2019 federal election our Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson explains
she's the prime minister's most senior
and trusted advisor Katie Telford has
served as Trudeau's Chief of Staff since
the Liberals took office in 2015 and
documents show that two years later the
threat of China meddling in Canada's
elections was on her radar Global News
has reviewed a June 2017 memo prepared
for the prime minister at telford's
request according to the document senior
intelligence officials had solid
evidence that Chinese agents were quote
assisting Canadian candidates running
for political offices working to
infiltrate quote all levels of
government
it warns that Chinese officials were
working to evade detection by Canadian
authorities using local pro-beijing
community groups to Target Canadian
politicians considered strategically
valuable the memo Global News reviewed
appears to be an advanced draft whether
it was ever finalized and sent to the
prime minister's office is unclear 99 of
the time when either the PM or the PM
senior staff asks for a memo it would go
in a statement Allison Murphy a
spokesperson for the Prime Minister said
the pmo could not comment on the Memo's
specifics or existence Murphy said the
prime minister is regularly briefed on
National Security including foreign
interference and that he and his staff
often seek additional information
Murphy stated the government will
continue to take action to protect
Canadians and work closely with our
allies and partners to respond to
illegal and unacceptable Behavior by
authoritarian States like China Global
News had previously reported on
documents that allege Beijing covertly
funded a clandestine Network in the 2019
election targeting at least 11
candidates a government source told
global news that warnings similar to the
information in the 2017 draft memo did
make it to the prime minister's office
it's the broad approach to China which
is becoming more assertive that leads me
to believe that if they've done this in
the past they're certainly going to do
it again and they may push a little bit
harder the liberal government is
defending its record pointing to actions
they've taken including introducing
legislation that would close some
loopholes for foreign funding in
elections and considering the
possibility of a foreign agent's
registry but some experts say that
Canada's allies have taken much more
aggressive action to safeguard their
democracies and question and why the
government isn't doing more in the face
of years of warnings Donna Mercedes
Stevenson thanks
ready for re-election ahead why Joe
Biden's State of the Union Address could
hint at a second presidential bid
the American president laid out his
agenda last night for the next year in
office and what many people watching the
State of the Union Address were looking
for are signs of whether Joe Biden
intends to run again in 2024. he not
only listed his achievements he called
out some Republicans and got heckled for
it
some Republicans want Medicare and
Social Security Sunset I'm not saying
it's a majority
let me give you
to contact my office I'll give you a
copy I'll give you a copy of The
Proposal folks
the idea is that we're not going to be
we're not going to be moved into being
threatened to default on the debt if we
don't respond
Reggie chiquini on the state of the
union and Biden's intentions
it's still not official my fellow
Americans but U.S President Joe Biden's
State of the Union Address left little
doubt that his re-election campaign is
ready to ramp up I've never been more
optimistic about our future that future
is built on two years of legislative
wins and a political career that's
taught this President how to break
through partisan roadblocks
one of the biggest things people were
looking for in the State of the Union
Address was would Joe Biden have the
vitality and the mental acuity to
actually continue in the role as
president what Joe Biden did was pretty
masterful halfway through Biden's
presidency his victories are being
outweighed by ongoing concerns namely
the economy one that is improving albeit
slowly inflation is coming down
take-home pay and workers is going up
slightly but his base isn't buying that
only 37 percent of Democrats want him to
seek a second term in 2024. in other
words don't expect Biden to announce
early what would happen if he announces
that he's not going to run or that he's
going to run we might see an exodus
coming out of his uh cabinet jumping
into the race to early could spark
others to do the same risking a loss of
the very people Biden needs for the next
two years with tensions high in the
republican-led house
regic Kinney Global News Washington
[Music]
fabulous moments next the stories of
survival from the earthquake zone
[Music]
the scenes from the earthquake zones in
turkey and Syria are difficult to watch
thousands of buildings have been reduced
to Rubble many of them collapsed while
people were asleep there are far too
many unhappy stories but sprinkled among
them are remarkable Tales of rescue Eric
Sorensen on the Hope amidst the despair
we yearned to see pictures like these at
a time like this Karam a little Syrian
boy who cannot possibly know how lucky
he is to be alive but he knows he's
happy
for The Rescuers the white helmets just
one life saved makes the hours of
digging and despair worthwhile
in the collapse of a large building it
is rare for even one person to be pulled
out alive easy easy easy but to witness
several seemingly miraculous rescues
over two days suggests how massive the
scale of Destruction has been across
Southern turkey and Northern Syria
for at least the second time a newborn
has emerged from the rubble in hattai
Turkey a tiny little one The Rescuers
both distraught and tender
every patient on every stretcher another
unlikely Story of Survival but for every
uplifting moment there are hours and now
days of heart-rending dread there are
some babies I have two nipples here and
I'm not sure if they're leaving
there's still
there's still pop because their house
their room is not totally eclipsed in
pile after pile of pulverized buildings
the dogged determination of Rescuers
leave no concrete block Unturned
the images are startling the white
helmets in besina Syria left a child his
father and sister to safety Elation for
a distraught community
an Israeli rescue team went through the
ceiling of one Turkish home to rescue
two people
even a little dog half buried in rubble
reportedly survived we're still in the
the phase of life-saving measures so
it's still about search and rescue it's
still about first aid medical support
for those who are injured the hope to
find survivors will fade the miraculous
moments will stop and anger will rise up
for buildings too weak and a response
too slow but hope is not exhausted not
yet this child trapped being given
capfuls of water the mayor of Istanbul
tweeted that he's okay
smile little guy
Eric Sorensen Global News
that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna freeze and help is
flooding in from around the world
War other to send a disaster relief team
this team of volunteers from BC is
already on Route with medical supplies
and rescue equipment hoping to make a
difference thanks for watching bye-bye
[Music]